got a little chippy just how frustrating
is this one for you
um first of all i've got it you know
give 76's credit they played a hard our
game you know
well does what he does and you know at
the end of the day
there they're a good team we competed um
but it's it's it's tough
okay like it's tough to to go out there
and see how we fight and compete and to
have a game like that taken from us and
i've never
ever wanted to to to blame a ref to
blame the fish i could say
we could have done more but this this is
getting out of hand you know there have
been games like this that we've won
there have been games like this that
we've we've lost but this whole
refereeing stuff and the way
we're we're nice we don't complain we
don't like we don't get frustrated you
know we fight through things and the
fact that we just continually
get get screwed in a way by this
you know like we we won this game in my
personal opinion you know but like i
said i'm gonna give them credit they won
whatever cool
but like this is cons it's commit it's a
consistent thing
and you know the question is can we can
we do it can we sustain it are we for
real number one like here the hell we
are and it's getting
it's getting [ __ ] ridiculous kkk that
this is this is what's happening
you know i mean we have a whole second
half of season to go and get ready for
but like i'm sick of it
to be honest with you we all are you
know and i think this is something that
just
it bites it eats me it eats at me man
and it's
i don't i don't y'all know what it is we
all know what it is but it's
it's really getting out of hand it's
really really really getting out of hand
and the league needs to do something
about this because i want to see the
last two minute report
i want to see it